I'm Mike Bishop retired professor of
microbiology and immunology at the
University of California San Francisco
where I served on the faculty for forty
eight years eleven of them as Chancellor
I was born and raised in a town of about
400 in rural Pennsylvania and my first
schooling was in a two-room schoolhouse
which accommodated eight grades under
the influence of a family physician I
had entered Gettysburg College is a
nominal pre-med I took the minimum
amount of science courses to qualify for
medical school although I like them I
like science from the get-go
I also liked literature philosophy other
than my general love for knowledge
learning was a course in comparative
anatomy so it remarkably from the
vantage point of evolution I had
literally never heard the term it hadn't
come up in grade school hadn't come up
in high school but this man used a
course of comparative anatomy to get
across the principles and the reality in
particular the reality of evolution it
changed the whole way I thought about
the natural world and has informed my
thinking ever since I wound up in
Harvard Medical School and for the first
time the instructions included an effort
to address how the knowledge was
obtained and that really turns me on by
the end of my second year I had decided
that I I really wanted to be a scientist
I had realized that I was more
interested in making discovering new
knowledge rather than apply known things
which is what most physicians do they
skillfully and compassionately apply no
knowledge and I had realized that I was
more interested in making discovering
new knowledge so I took an elective
course in animal viruses during my third
year in medical school where for the
first time I read and presented original
research publications and befriended the
instructor in fo the course a man named
Elmer Pfeffer corn my first year I was a
third-year medical student so I was
doing research with Elmer only a part
time most of the weekends and I was so
an avid of it possibility that on any
given day you're gonna find out
something that was never known before
and that happened to me a truly
wonderful number of times in my 48 years
it wasn't always a really important
thing but it was a new thing and that's
what gets you out of bed and drives you
on the days when nothing works and
that's what I found to be the most
motivating and gratifying part of the
career